today's world the physicians aren't
sharing the data the government's don't
have the methodologies to share the data
in the legislation in place and the
hospitals in this case or the
cybersecurity vendors want to keep that
data private and use it for competitive
advantage so what we've done with the
IBM x-force exchange is a really bold
step for IBM and we've taken our
treasure trove of threat intelligence
data over 700 terabytes worth spanning
almost 20 years and this is highly
actionable intelligence and we're
putting this information out there free
so that anybody can access it and really
taking the you know let's go compete on
the analytics and the intelligence we
can gather out of this in our products
let's not compete in the data itself so
are other companies putting their
information on this exchange absolutely
so over the course of the last month
we've had a thousand companies join the
IBM x-force exchange six of the top 10
retailers five the top 10 banks as well
as companies from everything from you
know automotive and transportation to
universities have all joined the x-force
exchange and can now share threat
intelligence data but can also share how
they're seeing that data evolve because
much like a healthcare crisis if this
was a you know a human virus these
things continue to evolve and morph and
we see them appearing in new places and
that's a big part of this is being able
to collaborate on what you're seeing
where you're seeing and how it's
infecting companies